congratulations on it it's amazing did
tyka call you up and say I have like
this just weird eccentric person or you
a fan of the Marvel movies like what
brought you to this room no and yes
let's see what had you know they there
was channels that met channels and dots
that connected other dust that wound
tyka and I up at the Chateau Marmont
where you spend your mornings having
breakfast I'm sure I've been there like
once on someone else's checks oh we met
there and we hit it off immediately I
loved him at least I I loved his movies
before Flight of the Conchords and
shadows all improvised movie and he said
from the start you know I think this is
going to be something in your vein and
that you can do and I want to kind of
make it into something that that you can
do and we're gonna improvise a lot and I
like improvisation so always kind of
like that but ya know it's very much
like you so how much was it you how much
was on the page well there was a lot
that was beautifully rendered on the
page but then tyka
you know is brilliant you know and he
said oh yeah let's fool around with this
and he said he said well if you have any
ideas and I would say as long as we're
here let's hear I can talk about this
and this and I would do that and then he
would say we'll keep the camera rolling
because I got 23 other ideas and he
would go say say this say that well how
about this and so we would do that so
when I saw the movie a few days ago it
was a surprise to me I had nobody told
me either what they could have gone in a
lot of different directions so it was
like that that's how we did it I'm so
glad that you said that - because I
can't wait to see the extra footage when
like the DVD comes out of like all the
different versions that they show we did
some fun stuff there's if your state
till the end credits the ND did you see
that yeah
I enjoyed it too I stayed anytime anyone
leaves in Marvel movie I'm like why did
you leave so I really is always kind of
a little so the last thing I was gonna
say is I feel like you've had this great
long career but recently I feel like
you're like Internet's own celebrity
because like the Internet is just
embraced you in a way that's bananas
I like if you noticed it like what's it
like when you're doing like your live
shows now if people are coming in there
with memes and rock well we do a show
every week there it's really fun I like
it
people come up yes their memes they have
tattoos of me sometimes that I like to
see it's really fun I like it and then I
have a kind of an embarrassing fetish
that my wife is like but I like to go on
all I have is Instagram okay so I go on
Instagram hashtag Jeff Goldblum to see
what pictures have been posted of us
together and people do nice drawings of
me that I like to see they're wrapping
me but um am I gonna get my song on the
way out yes did you know any jazz
standard you started all sing along with
[Music]
oh my congratulations this film is
absolutely hilarious I laughed so much
during the screening so when I was
talking to Chris he said you know when
you came on board you both had this
vision to sort of change it and shift it
totally so yeah how did you make that
approach because it looks like you
looked a lot of the old movies too and
like use that for the comedy yeah yeah
well we'd like because Ragnarok is like
the destruction of the old world and the
rebirth of the new and without being
getting too philosophical about it we
destroyed the kind of memory of those
first two films and used all of that
history to like reboot the franchise and
without having to cast anyone again I
have anyway to have me having to recast
it it's just really cool it was like oh
do you want to like change your
character sure I want to change my
character and make it more fun you want
to change your character yeah I don't
want to be boring scientist guy anymore
you want to change your character so
that was basically everyone had the
opportunity to come in and make it
interesting for themselves and make it
fun to go to work and that's really
where all the lunacy came from yeah when
I was talking to Jeff he definitely said
how you just let him play and have fun I
mean casting him is that pretty much why
you went for it so yeah Jeff he was like
okay I remember the casting meeting
Kevin Feige and I were across this
boardroom table and though everyone was
looking around these bits paper people's
names all over them you know and
possible people to play Jeff Cobb and we
both like to the page so it's the
possible people to play the Grand Master
we're both in the same page at the same
time with head Chiefs based on it and we
was with Jeff Goldblum it's it's him
okay so you want to like make a short
list is that no it's that's it
that's only him just go after him really
yeah and so we did and never greats yeah
I mean it's I loved his character as I
felt like what you were able to do with
him but then also your character coorg
oh yeah so when you're filming on set
were you just off to the side like
throwing out the
or how did you do that yeah but usually
like when I direct I'll be like you know
like you guys were talking then I'll be
speaking people lines a lot and being a
ninja I'm not to ruin the takes by
laughing and which I did ruin a lot of
those takes and then and then if I'm in
the scene then I you know I don't I make
sure it's nothing too complicated camera
wise where I have to like do a lot of
choreography or like just standing
around saying stuff yeah you know I like
to comment my character characters are
like doing the most just comment on
things they just like write have a
running commentary and they just talk
about theirs describe things and they
like or help a characters you know like
and what we're doing shadows my
characters like the tour guide
throughout the world
yeah and in this one Korg is like the
tour guide first okay yeah I saw that
screening at in Austin at the Alamo
that's so great so last thing Chris let
us know that there's gonna be another
Thor does that mean you're gonna come
back cuz I mean I feel like you've
turned the world you can't hand it off
to someone else at this one oh I
wouldn't know it would be like giving
one of my children in the way so you can
take full of that past but I can't bring
myself to do that and so you know I mean
if it happens I'll definitely come back
and do it Chris says he's down so more
about me because you know you can't have
me without Korg you kind of called
without me as director so it's like a
two years okay it's a lot of navigating
on the salary thank you Chris
congratulations on the film it's
hilarious and so much fun and I heard
that you kind of wanted to go in this
direction was this before Tyga came on
or when he came on I heard you were
kicking us off uh yeah before talked you
came on I was pretty bored of myself and
what I was doing is the character and
and really wanted to do something
different you know and I called Kevin
Feige and said we got to change this up
a bit and and cut the head break for
hammer do all sorts of different
aesthetic things and
the Annunaki came on board and actually
new target before he had the first
interview and I called him and I said I
think we should pretend that we don't
know each other and let it be Marvel's
idea and and it worked out fine so after
he finds out he gets the job do y'all
have like a celebratory moment together
where you like do a little dance and
like call each other a little dance then
we thought looked at each other and
thought oh wow there's a whole lot of
people relying on us we gotta pull
yourself down but you know the good
thing was he also had the same
I think feelings about what this world
could be and what this character could
be and and and it was as bored of me as
I was I mean let's be honest you played
Thor a lot like flying you know but I've
sort of built-in parameters of the
character that you know that that I
thought he had to abide by and had to
speak a certain way and move certain way
in this film really was I was like just
you know what I'm just gonna take a risk
and throw it all away and play a
different character you know and it's
gonna fit the universe because it's this
is what were part of but you know that I
think experimenting and taking risks is
where the special parts of it all
happened yeah and the genre in general I
mean we were getting a lot I mean it's
common but I'm loving that we're getting
these movies but this movie is a perfect
example of like when you flip it on its
head I can get yeah oh great I think you
have an obligation do you know or Judi
just sort of do something different
otherwise you're just collecting a
paycheck you know that but for a lot of
us I think it's about pushing it to
another place you know it's great I was
just gonna say to with Tessa
I feel like y'all's dynamic in the film
it's just so great so can you talk a
little bit about what it was like on set
and when she came on and oh she's
amazing it's funny I read this script
and I didn't see the character the way
she portrayed it you know and and it's
funny because I could try and play the
character how I wanted but unless
someone's pushing that atomy you
it's not gonna happen and she came on
set and just had this whole difference
of attitude and she had this brush that
our confidence this sort of you know
arrogance at times and and and and so on
and which put Thor on his back foot and
all of a sudden he was vulnerable and
the fan of the Valkyrie and so on so
brought out a whole different thing in
him you know and I couldn't be more
thankful for what she brought to the
character and her attitude and and also
her confidence to come in and do that
because it wasn't written like that you
know she came in and made a decision to
go I'm doing a hand solo sort of you
know quality to this this this character
thank you so much first of all I feel
tyka put his stamp on this film so much
and even with you both as Hulk Ana's
Bruce so how did he talk to you about
the changes in the character evolving
cuz this is how many films now that
you've been playing the whole way this
is well yeah the third one yeah we were
just looking to crack it open you know
and really we were just but always
laughing talk what if he does this what
if he does that and and you know we knew
that we just we wanted to break the
forms you know we wanted to break all
the norm to kind of break the rules with
it Chris wanted to the franchise we
wanted to do that with the franchise
wanted to do it but we also wanted to do
it in a way that made sense that also
told a story not just to do it but to
have it also serviced the story so so it
was like really trying to find we wanted
to be human you want to be human to be
and tyke it does that so well he he he's
quirky conversations and real moments
with people that are surprising and kind
of touching as well and there are the
real things like you don't you guys
don't like me I don't want to be nobody
likes me on earth why would I want to go
back let's just talk about like glad you
brought it up to like not to spoil
anything but both the Hulk and Banner
have like real
character arcs like the Hulk like you
know I've shed a little bit of a tear a
little bit yeah it's cool man yeah he's
you know we all have volcanoes you know
we all have that part of us like that
monster that you know just wants to be
loved and liked and and Banner just
wants to be free you know that and they
both want to be free you know it's so
it's so Kevin came to me and you know
Kevin Feige and and Lou Esposito and
Brad
we're like ask me like what would you do
if you had to stand a little Hulk like
what was the story being I was like I
think it should be this this this and
this and it's and like this and like how
about if we take that and we stretch
that between Thor 3 and Avengers 4 so
you do that character arc over for these
next three movies so that you will
basically have a standalone Hulk movie
but it'll be buried in these you know
and I was like that sounds cool the
Internet's mad right now they're still
gonna probably big bug you at every
change maybe after all this Universal
will finally be like okay just take just
take them we don't wanna talk anymore
it's the pain in the ass they won't
leave us alone please please your lips
to God's ears
please but right but so what you're
seeing now is the beginning of that I
can't wait for it and again like thank
you so much for this character I just
love what you guys are like yeah those
guys are glad you brought up Chris my
heroes last thoughts you guys definitely
improvised a lot I mean can you just
talk about maybe a day where you just
couldn't keep it together like what were
you doing cuz y'all improvise so much I
imagine there were days you couldn't
stop laughing there was some innocent
scene it's not in the movie but it'll be
in the DVD where I'm eating this pasta
I'm starving Bruce he's always starving
saying eating this Boston you realize
it's a worm he's been eating a worm it's
like it's the car thing he freaks but
he's also it's a very funny scene it
didn't end up in a movie but he's trying
to he's trying to use Dumbo as an
analogy for Thor to understand his life
and it's so stupid
and here just riffing off of this and it
was it was a very funny day we were
laughing so hard and then there was
another day when this the stoop seen
when we banners wearing Tony's clothes
and he's trying to get him through and
we sit down and we came up with the
whole thing like you want you're using
me for the hall gross that's gross man
and we were laughing so hard during that
scene we we had we couldn't do the scene
yeah thank you so much so Tom i'ma ask
you exist our third Thor but the first
time would Tiger like what did he do to
just feel like he just changed the whole
franchise of this film yeah I mean I
mean it's he has such a spirited sense
of humor and such a clear taste and you
know I came to it a little bit later
than Chris did but but they already had
decided they were going to shake it up a
bit and that it was going to be funny
and kind of out there and to really
enjoy it or just it I don't know like a
kind of a shot of humor through the
whole thing and I loved it I mean it's
it's I think to have that sincerely to
have the privilege of coming back to do
a third floor film for both of us you
know the you know to come back to the
plated character again you want to find
new and fresh ways of doing it and take
it just the kind of lot I lighted on
this new tone with a new story and and
it was really fun yeah I do feel you put
a spin on it and especially Tessa with
your character I just felt so much of
his humor with it but also such care
because I feel like let's be honest
there's just a generation of feeling
fans that look like me that are just
like yes girl please yes I know you've
dealt with a lot since the casting so
just how awesome it is it now that
you're like you'll get to see how great
this is it's great I mean you know this
is an intrusive thing that I look
forward to is when it isn't so much of a
talking point you know I mean I'm so
happy that the Marvel you know would
take a rest
guess what it is not to you know
completely honor the source material is
you know how she looks but to me the
thing that is so important with all of
these characters is that you capture the
the spirit of the character in the comic
books and you know what we what color we
are has very little to do with who we
are as people and so that's the thing
that I just concentrated on this is
trying to bring sort of her great and
how dynamic she is in in the comics to
life yeah I really feel they they killed
how dynamic she is cuz I felt like your
character for once like I mean I hate to
say it even as a woman like sometimes
they don't have agency but she's the
hard-drinking like would be one so what
was it like I know you guys have some
scene together but you and Kate have
some great scenes together like going
against her and going against Chris like
what did you have the most fun filming
oh all of it was fun I mean to go
against it but but everyone you know and
and the truth is I'm sort of like felt
very much like the new comer because I
am structurally but there were a lot of
new folks you know people in this world
and I think even for you know folks that
have been around and playing these
characters that are celebrated like Tom
said it's an it's a new spin so in that
way it kind of felt like we were all
newbies yeah
Ragnarok is about kind of destroying the
old and in with the new and so in that
way it felt like I was just in good
company we're all in it together of
trying to sort through what we what we
do in this third installment no great
well there I got a wrap-up but I want to
ask what was your favorite line or
moment from her and then what was your
favorite line or moment from him if
you've got one it doesn't spoil too much
it's my favorite line from you yet so
many that's why I'm like open our moment
I mean there's a like why the way you
come into your entrance is extraordinary
the way you used enter the way you come
into the film is it's like fierce
and confident and hilarious hmm are you
probably you don't know what I'm
referring to
I know I know I mean I remember shooting
it yeah I just like the way he says my
name no I'm Angie I just like when
you're like say it what do you say oh
you're that when you do when you
discover that she's about everybody I
love to do that senior Valkyrie oh wow
Hey
[Music]
you